icarly was one of those childhood
defining shows but the truth is it had a
lot of unanswered questions from really
dark to some of the more lighthearted
secrets we'll take a look at what
Nickelodeon kept away from its viewers
wait till you see all the secret
connections to your favorite shows don't
forget to give this video a thumbs up
and subscribe to the things now let's
check out 10 dark and not so dark
secrets in iCarly Nickelodeon doesn't
want you to know they predicted the
ending there have been several
speculations on reasons why icarly.com
this cussing drama between the cast
since we all know jennette mccurdy
appeared to have clashed with ariana
grande on Sam and cat although even that
seems to be a rumor but the truth is
Nickelodeon was hiding the fact that the
creator of the show knew how icarly was
going to end from the beginning and even
before that actually remember the scene
when Carly sees her dad Dan Schneider
had it in mind since 2008 one year after
the show first aired it does make us
wonder if he ever wanted to wrap up the
series earlier than intended or was
season 7 just the perfect time to let
these Nickelodeon kids finally grow up
and become stars beyond iCarly we'll
never know but it's kind of scary to
think that the creators might just have
the ending of your favorite show already
written in your head we didn't expect it
to happen to iCarly and we can't even
think what kind of secrets some creators
hold in their brain to be fair
Nickelodeon didn't have a lot to do with
the secret but we have a feeling they
made Dan think a lot about the ending of
the show through the icarly gears if you
know what we mean sneaky websites okay
this one is not a dark secret at all
it's actually super fun then you can try
it out yourself so you know how iCarly
had plenty of websites mentioned on the
show right it turns out those websites
are actually real the same way you can
actually call Sam's phone number and get
her voicemail you can visit all those
websites the cast mentioned over the
years well sort of Nickelodeon was
actually pretty smart because they
bought the domains for the websites such
as sampuckett.com
and have them redirected to the official
iCarly site someone had to have kept
track of every website they mentioned
and
the domain in advance which seems like a
lot of work the funny thing is if you go
and check out how much these domains
costs you'll see they're really not that
expensive at all although we're pretty
sure iCarly owns the copyright so
there's actually no way you could ever
buy a domain like sampuckett.com
buying domains was actually really smart
of them considering how many people out
there could have used that to their
advantage and put kids that watch ICarly
in danger this show really did a lot of
behind the scenes work didn't it Harry
Potter have you ever wondered what your
favorite TV characters are actually
reading when you see them with a book or
a newspaper you're about to find out
remember the eye fence episode where Sam
had to read a book to win a bet that
book was called the penny treasure but
the title of the book doesn't actually
exist even though Sam really praised the
book and said it was like having a TV in
your head which is an amazing analogy
unless you're a huge bookworm you
probably never noticed that there's no
such thing as the penny treasure but the
cast revealed that they had to
creatively hide a popular book as the
penny treasure can you guess which one
it was it talks about a wizard called
Harry yep it was Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows the team used the book
but replaced the cover with a fake cover
of the penny treasure to make you feel
like they were actually reading the real
thing okay but now we want to know about
all the other potential fake books from
TV shows and the original books they
used on set Drake & Josh crossover do
you know just how many icarly references
you can find in Drake and Josh it's
pretty impressive but there's one
specific reference you've probably never
acknowledged and it's actually pretty
mind-blowing how nickelodeon tried to
hide it from its viewers the last
episode of Drake and Josh
appeared just as iCarly started airing
in the episode called really big shrimp
we see the premiere featuring one of the
movies called
now she's Carly get it it was a very
subtle hint for the viewers and probably
not many noticed it with all the dark
rumors that Drake and Josh
actually got cancelled that one must
have heard of it that icarly made sure
paid homage to the Nickelodeon show that
brought it pretty high ratings with
every episode you can also find plenty
of Drake & Josh references in ICarly
Drake Bell even appears in an episode
called I blue and an i Toph at cakes
like Nickelodeon felt bad for ending
Drake and Josh after all high security
did you know that there was one prop on
the Nickelodeon set that was more
special than anything else
seriously people felt really protective
over it so much so the Creator actually
took it home every single day to make
sure it's kept safe it's Sam's remote
seriously back in the day this thing
looks like it was from the future and it
was actually the only prop of its kind
so it was extremely important to keep it
safe at all times and the team
definitely did that because years after
years nothing ever happened to the
remote well at least as far as we know
but we're sure Nickelodeon had some dark
secrets they've never revealed to the
public if you remember the final episode
you know that it ends on quite a sad
note as Sam finally lets go of her
iconic remote and hand it over to Carly
it assumed that the remote has 93 sounds
and it uses Bluetooth technology to send
those sounds to sam show well this
little remote is no longer unique as you
can now get plenty of mock up toys for
kids that really miss iCarly we have no
idea which crew member actually ended
with Sam's remote but it seems like a
really sacred item Spanish outbursts we
all know that for some reason Freddie is
able to speak full Spanish but have you
noticed that the secret behind his
random Spanish outburst is something
Nickelodeon doesn't want you to know
about we actually never got the answer
about them even though the creator of
the show said he'll eventually explained
the reason but if you remember the
show's finale you know that freddie was
also about to explain his reason for his
Spanish outbursts but he actually got
cut off so the secret will probably
never be revealed but anyways we want to
hear it from you do you have any
theories about this we have a feeling
this was one of those character traits
that was created for comedic purposes
but the Creator probably doesn't even
know the meaning of it himself seriously
Dan Schneider were still waiting for the
reveal why freddie is actually able to
speak Spanish so fluently do you think
we'll ever learn or is this just
Nickelodeon messing with us
fever do you remember the I won't cancel
the show episode from season 3 it's the
episode where Sam ends up in a detention
center and doesn't really appear for the
entire episode the episode gives the
viewers a chance to focus on Carly and
Spencer although it's equal
as entertaining but why would Sam
missing in this specific episode in the
first place well it turns out that
jennette mccurdy had high fever during
the filming of that episode and had to
miss out this made Sam the first and
only main character to ever miss an
icarly episode jeanette being sick
resulted in the entire episode airdate
being pushed back for a week and we have
a feeling that episode had to have been
rewritten when Jeanette got sick we have
a feeling Nickelodeon had a strict
schedule for their main actors as being
sick can significantly affect everything
as we've learned from Jeanette's story
the jelly O company were you ever
jealous of the rooms you saw on the show
we have to admit Carly's bedroom was
absolutely gorgeous
most of the set was actually designed by
a company called the jelly oak company
maybe that's why the colors and the
designs really managed to pop and give
that iconic icarly look let's be honest
that cupcake table in Carly's room was
pretty impressive and remember the gummy
bear lights in the living room they were
made by the company too so yep all that
furniture is completely unique to the
show but there's some good news we bet
you never even knew about you can
actually get the iconic gummy bear
lights from the actual jelly o company's
store they also feature the ice-cream
bench from my Carly's bedroom and plenty
of more custom furniture and to think
Nickelodeon never let us know that you
can actually get some of the furniture
that was on your favorite show sure they
might be expensive but hey we have a
feeling there are plenty of hardcore
fans out there that would love to have
those gummy bear lights George okay this
one is just a little bit inappropriate
just like any Nickelodeon show iCarly
also had plenty of wacky moments that
make you want to go WTF one of them was
definitely the strange talking bra that
told even stranger stories - it's way
too young iCarly audience
it gets even creepier when you learn
that the voice of the bra belonged to
the guy that also played mr. Hanning the
science teacher we don't even want to
think that those two characters might be
connected on the show speaking of
Secrets have you ever noticed this one
George the bra lived in a room 34 C but
did you know its size apparently it's 34
C the same as his original room
this totally doubles up as one of the
most inappropriate things on icarly come
on Nickelodeon what's with the weird
inappropriate stuff like this on the
show that was meant for kids for pretty
sure not even parents appreciate a
random talking bra character Zoey 101
let's face it nothing will ever top Zoey
101 and Nickelodeon probably knows it
since they managed to squeeze in quite a
few secret references in iCarly we
already mentioned George the bra but it
turns out that's a 36d room reference
also connects to Zoey 101 but this
reference really blew our minds
this secret isn't dark it's just
mind-blowing Zoey 101 first aired in
2005 but did you know that an icarly
actor actually appeared as a side
character in season two her look from
that side character actually inspired
her character in iCarly it's of course
jennette mccurdy who appeared in an
episode called bad girl if you look at
her clothes and her looks
you'll notice that Sam looks pretty much
the same even though icarly didn't air
until two years after two zoey 101
episode sneaky nickelodeon thought no
one would notice this secret didn't they
Jeanette's even wearing the same type of
clothes you'd see Sam where do you think
Dan Schneider knew back then that she'll
become this huge star and play along
miranda cosgrove on one of our favorite
Nickelodeon shows ever and that's all
for our video don't forget to subscribe
to the things and tell us how you felt
about this video thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]